[Générique] À travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle.
C'est... c'est... c'est l'épopée temporelle !
Narrateur : Bon, j'avais dit que j'avais démissionné. La production m'a convaincu de rester.
Nos héros viennent de découvrir que le méchant qui veut modifier le temps n'est autre qu'une
deuxième Iris et le docteur Simon était au courant et il va tout nous expliquer ! Ahah j'ai hâte d'écouter !
Pour info la production l'a doublé mon salaire.
Iris 2 : Bah allez papa du monde réel.
Explique pourquoi il y a deux versions de moi !
Iris 1 : Deux versions de moi, tu veux dire.
Dr Simon : Très bien, les enfants. Je vais tout vous raconter.
Au fond,
je n'ai jamais vraiment été un très bon père.
Iris 1 : Ça on le sait déjà.
Raconte-nous pourquoi mon double veut détruire le temps ! Dr. Simon : Voilà, un peu après qu'on évacue Hitler dans une faille spatio-temporelle,
j'ai commencé à ressentir un sentiment étrange.
C'était le regret.
Ohh j'ai regretté de mettre si mal occupé de toi Iris.
Alors du coup j'ai... Eliott : décidé de vous excuser auprès de votre fille et de repartir sur des bases plus saines. Dr. Simon : Quoi, mais
non pas du tout ! Bon, vous savez la simulation auto provient l'autre Thomas.
Thomas : Ah oui, Thomas en mousse !
Dr. Simon : Ah oui, c'est ça.
Je vous ai menti à propos de cette simulation; ce n'était pas une simple expérience qui a buggé, non.
Face à mes regrets d'avoir est un mauvais père et bien,
j'ai crée un monde parfait avec une nouvelle Iris, un monde virtuel où j'étais un père présent et affectueux,
un monde simple et heureux ou Iris a vécu une vie idéale puis...
je l'ai extraites de ce monde virtuel, je l'ai imprimé pour qu'elle devienne ma fille et c'est
cette Iris qui nous menace
actuellement. Thomas : Ouah, c'est clairement le pire plan que j'ai entendu de ma vie. Mais pourquoi t'es méchante, Iris en mousse ? Iris 2 : Moi ?
Méchante ? Haha !
Vous plaisantez, j'ai vécu toute ma vie dans un monde parfait et sodas je suis projeté dans ce que vous appelez la
réalité un monde qui pue où les gens se tuent où il y a du sexe où tout est triste
Thomas : Attends, attends, il y'a pas de sexe dans cette simulation ?
Dr Simon : Ah oui, je ne vais pas trop vite ma fille se fasse bois terre. Eliott : Mais c'est pour ça qu'on a détruit le Kama Sutra.
Iris 2 : Qui pas être coincé dans ce que vous appelez la réalité,
j'essaie de la reprogrammer pour qu'elle ne devienne plus supportable Iris 1 : Tu voulais supprimer le sexe ?
C'est pour ça que tu voulais détruire Internet ! Iris 2 : Oui, pour supprimer la pornographie et aussi les commentaires négatifs !
J'aime pas ça, je suis susceptible.
Je déteste Twitter. Iris 1 : Eh bah, ma pauvre, ton plan n'a aucun sens. La Buse : Vous dites quand je peux utiliser ma hache,
d'accord ? Thomas : Et pourquoi le Titanic ?
Iris 2 : Parce que c'est le premier film que cet idiot de père m'a montré quand je suis arrivée ici. J'ai découvert
la tristesse à cause de ce film. Dr. Simon : Ah bon ?
Iris 2 : Quels sentiments horribles ! Dr Simon : Voilà, mais moi je croyais que c'était un film cool...
Non ? Ah bon, je me suis toujours endormi avant la fin. Iris 2 : Et les machines de guerre et la puissance américaine et les esclaves !
Vous m'avez empêchée d'améliorer votre monde, donc je vais faire
la modification que j'aurais dû faire depuis le début.
Je vais vous éliminer avec mon désintégrateur proton et ensuite, je prenne enfin redéfinir le monde
Thomas : Attends, attends ! La Buse : C'est maintenant pour la hache. Thomas : Écoute, Iris en mousse, il y quelques choses que t'as mal compris sur notre réalité.
Tu vois,'y aura toujours un humain pour créer une arme pour
inventer le porno, il y aura toujours un humain pour tuer un autre humain.
Tu vois, tu essayes de changer l'histoire mais ça changera jamais l'humanité. Tu peux faire autant de modifications que tu veux
il faut que tu comprennes qu'ici on est tous comme ça
fait que de la merde. Alors pour cette arme... KB29 : Je crois qu'il a raison, patronne. Iris 1 : Ouais, ouais, c'est vrai, autre moi, tu ne peux pas changer
l'humanité. C'est vrai ?
Iris 2 : Mais oui, je ne vais pas vous tuer.
Tu m'as ouvert les yeux. Je sais ce que je dois faire.
KB29, Eliott ! En route ! KB29 : On y va, patronne. Eliott : Ok. Iris 2 : Adieu, vous autres.
Thomas : Hein ? Pourquoi adieu ?
Iris 2 : *rire machiavélique*
La Buse : Ah bah bravo ! Iris : Elle est partie. La Buse : On a loupé l'occasion de l'ouvrir le crâne. Iris : Papa,
tu es clairement le pire père. Tu mets tout le temps ton intelligence scientifique au service de ta bêtise émotionnelle mais on n'a pas de temps
et tu vas commencer par te rattraper tout de suite ! Est-ce que tu arrives à détecter leurs traces temporelles ? Dr. Simon : Ah attendez, attendez. Oui.
Ils sont à ces coordonnées ?
Lapin : Ça fait loin, ça. Iris : Il faut les suivre, j'ai l'impression que ça va mal finir.
Papa, toi, tu bouges pas et tu fais rien. Dr. Simon : D'accord ! Tu arrives. Thomas : On va où ? Lapin : Je vous préviens, il y a une majoration d'environ 2,5.
Accrochez-vous !
Vous voilà, arrivés à destination. Il y a 66 millions d'années. On n'oublie pas mettre cinq étoiles, hein ? La Buse : Chaudes par ici. Thomas : Quoi ?
La Buse : Il fait bon mais y a une petite brise. C'est comme ça que vous dites ? Iris : Ah oui oui c'est ça.
Iris : Vite ! Ouvrez l'oeil et trouvez moi cette pute de fausse moi avant qu'elle fasse n'importe quoi
Thomas : Ouah, des dinosaures !
C'est encore moi qui suis bête ou ils ont pas du tout la tête qu'on imaginait ? La Buse : Moi, je me pose que c'est un nidesaure.
Iris : On n'a pas le temps de discuter zoologie, Thomas. Les dinosaures ont toujours été comme ça : plutôt grand, balèze avec de belles plumes aux couleurs chatoyantes.
Cherche plutôt la fausse Iris. Lapin : Non, parce que je me suis permis de checker, vous n'avez pas encore pris le temps de mettre mes cinq
étoiles une seule fois et-
Thomas : Justement c'est des plumes qui nous font bizarres. On dirait des grosses poules de neige.
Iris : C'est à cause des films débiles
que tu n'as aucun sens d'un point de vue scientifique. C'est vous qui avez décidé qu'il n'y avait pas de plumes.
La Buse : Là, oh ! L'autre Iris dans le ciel !
Iris : Quoi ?
Elle est sur le dos de KB29 ?
Je savais pas que le robot pouvait voler. Thomas : Vous avez vraiment des options de plus en plus folle de rembaucher le café.
C'est vrai. Iris : Eliott, tels à toi. Eliott : Il y a plus de 100 options supplémentaires. Mais bon je suis sûr qu'il y en a au moins.
72 pas très utile. Iris : T'es qu'un sale traître. La Buse : Mon des-amis de fer. Eliott : C'est vous, les traîtres. Thomas : Oh, la mauvaise foi !
Tu réagis comme un humain, bravo mon pote.
Alors comment ça se passe, la liberté ? Eliott : Pour l'instant ça consiste beaucoup à obéir à une autre Iris, donc
ça change pas grand chose. La Buse : Euh, c'est normal que le soleil s'approche ?
Eliott : Ce n'est pas le soleil, c'est une météorite.
Iris & Thomas : Quoi ?
La Buse : C'est quoi une météorite ?
Thomas : Là !
Iris 2 : *rire machiavélique*
Iris 2 : Vous avez voulu nous suivre !
C'est encore mieux, vous serez aux premières
loges pour voir la destruction de cette météorite ! Les dinosaures vont pouvoir vivre tranquillement.
Et l'espèce humaine ne verra
jamais le jour ! Merci, Thomas, pour cette idée ! Thomas : Je ne me rappelle ça, je ne revendique pas ça  ?
Iris : Elle est en train d'annuler l'espèce humaine.
La Buse : Alors un peu trop loin pour ma hache.
Thomas : Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Iris : Ah merde, on est cloués au sol, c'est pas comme si on avait un robot capable de voler, nous. Regardez là !
Iris : Eh, j'ai vraiment un bon cru du
Eliott : Vous voulez un dernier café en attendant ? Iris : C'est pas le moment ! Thomas : Un allongé, s'il te plaît. Eliott : Avec deux sucres,
comme tu aimes. Iris 2 : KB29, la météorite est suffisamment proche. Détruis-la ! KB29 : Accroche-toi.
Iris 2 : Rayon de glace !
La Buse : Ouah, c'est quoi ça...
Iris : KB29 a un rayon
glaçon ! Eliott : Oui.
Eliott : Elle fait des cafés frappés avec et ça marche très bien pour détourner les météorites aussi.
Thomas : Délicieux, ton café. Moi, j'aime pas le café glacé, c'est encore une option débile. Eliott : Merci, Thomas.
Iris 2 : Et voilà ! Plus de météorites et bientôt, plus dieu ! KB29, pose-nous au sol. KB29 : Atterrissage.
Lapin : Ah, putain. Merde, je vais disparaître.
Iris 2 : Alors, les perdants ça fait quoi de se faire annuler comme une bête simulation. C'est fini !
Iris 2 : Ciao, les nazes. KB29, tue-les ! KB29 : J'en fait mon affaire. Iris 2 : J'ai une dernière chose à faire dans le futur.
La Buse : Elle est partie. Iris : Oh non, elle a gagné !
Iris : L'humanité va disparaître, les dinosaures sont pas morts. KB29 : La bonne nouvelle, c'est que vous n'allez pas être coincés ici longtemps vu que je dois vous tuer.
La Buse : Non, la bonne nouvelle, c'est que je vais enfin utiliser ma hache !
Je vais dire « pomme »
Branche à robot !
KB29 : Eliott, protège-moi ! Eliott : J'ai une question d'abord. Pourquoi Iris de nous a abandonnés ? KB29 : Peu importe.
KB29 : Pourquoi tu poses toujours autant de questions, t'as un bug ? Aide-moi plutôt à tuer tes anciens maîtres que chipoter. Eliott : Je ne- je ne
suis pas d'accord. KB29 : Quoi ? Monsieur le robot soit disant humain va me faire croire qu'il a du libre arbitre ?
KB29 : Eliott, fais-moi un café. Eliott : Ok.
Voilà un café pour KB29. KB29 : Tu vois, tu ne fais qu'obéir, stupide machine.
Mais attends. C'est pas du café ? C'est- Eliott : du jus de tomates.
Quoi ? Oh. [marmottent] Oh, bleh, du jus de tomates. Oh.
Eliott : Tu vois, je fais ce que je veux. Je suis
libre. Contrairement à toi qui ne fait qu'obéir.
J'ai trahi mes amis et maintenant, je ne les abandonnerai plus.
KB29 : Tu m'as énervé ! Bouge pas, je te gèle, je t'éclate en milles morceaux !
Eliott : Pas si d'abord, je mot tout détruit dans ta face de sale esclave. KB29 : Super, allez. Eliott : Auto-destruction dans
5. 4. 3- Iris : Non, non non ! Fais pas ça, Eliott, non !
Non, non, non !
Eliott : Au revoir, les amis.
La Buse : Non non non non non !
*son d'une explosion*
Narrateur : Ainsi s'achève la vie de nos héros.
Corrigez vos livres d'histoire.
Les derniers humains sont morts il y a 66 millions d'années dans une explosion de machines à café. Les dinosaures vont rester sur la terre très longtemps...
et continuer d'évoluer et croyez-moi,
voir un dinosaure et qu'un petit chapeau dans sa voiture électrique, aller à son boulot de community manager, ah bah c'est rigolo.
Attendez, mais quel est ce bruit ? La Buse : Mais mes amis, vous m'entendez ?
Eliott : Chut ! Fermez-la ! C'est pas fini !
La Buse : Woohoo... Mes des amis...
Les vivants !
Iris : La Buse ! [La Buse] Doucement, prenez vos temps. Vous avez dit gelés pendant à peu près cinq ans.
Thomas : Quoi ? Cinq ans ?
La Buse : Oui j'ai fait un feu. Ah oui, voilà. Ça y est.
Iris : Ah, ça fait du bien.
La Buse : Quand les robots ont fait boum, il y a dû voir qu'est sorti du méchant robot et ça vous à transformer en glaçon.
Moi, j'étais de l'autre côté. Il y a du feu qu'est sorti d'Eliot ce qui explique cette brûlure sur mon visage.
Thomas : Oh, stylé !
Thomas : Et c'est quoi cette armure ultra badass ?
La Buse : Ah, ça !
Je me suis construit cette armure à partir des restes des robots. Elle fait du café d'ailleurs. Tenez, réchauffez-vous.
Iris : Ça fait du bien.
Iris : Mais La Buse comment t'as fait ? La Buse : Après l'explosion, j'ai ramassé des bouts de métal. Dans l'un d'eux y avait un papier. C'était un message
et une notice.
J'ai mis trois ans à construire l'armure tout en me nourrissant de nidosaures et de fruits fermentés.
Iris : Attends, Eliott, il est
détruit ? Fais voir ce papier.
Thomas : Enfin nous a déjà fait le coup une fois,
diversement se re-télécharger dans une autre machine et en soutenant- Iris : Non, non, Thomas, désolée, on dirait un vrai adieu.
Iris : Mes amis, j'espère que vous pourrez lire ce message. Je me sacrifie.
Malheureusement je n'ai plus de sauvegarde car il n'y a plus de futur. Je crois que j'ai compris ce qui différencie l'humain du robot.
C'est la mort.
Thomas : Quoi ?
Iris : En disparaissant, je veux mourir comme un homme
comme un ami qui veut vous protéger. Si quelqu'un trouve ce papier,
j'ai mis une notice pour construire une armure avec mes composants. Il n'y a pas besoin de savoir lire, ce sont des dessins.
Si vous connaissez Ikea, vous devriez vous en sortir. [Thomas] Mais c'est débile !
Thomas : Pourquoi il se sacrifie ? La Buse : Des toits qu'il n'est pas mort enfin, cet armure
m'a vraiment aidé à tuer tous les nidosaures. Iris & Thomas : Quoi ? La Buse : Avant de vous dégeler, vous m'avez dit qu'il fallait tuer tous les nidosaures,
c'est ce que j'ai fait. Thomas : Sur la terre entière ? La Buse : Ouais, c'est super grand dedans.
L'armure m'a aidé à me déplacer vite et à tuer vite.
Il ne reste plus que ces deux petits nidosaures dans cette cage.
Un garçon et une fille.
Je me suis dit que ça vous ferait plaisir d'en tuer. Thomas : Oh non merci. La Buse : Tant pis pour vous. Alors toi, t'es la première.
C'est ça. C'est sur mais bon c'est la seule façon de sauver l'humanité.
Et maintenant le deuxième !
Iris : Attends, attends La Buse ! S'il n'y a plus qu'un il pourra pas se reproduire donc on n'a pas besoin de l'éliminer.
Lapin : Oh le mignon petit dinosaure !
Iris : Le lapin ! Ça veut dire que ça a marché ? L'humanité est sauvée ! La Buse : Ho ho, super, les des-amis.
Je veux adopter ce petit nidosaure, trop mignon alors. Thomas : C'est fou, c'est le dernier dinosaure.
La Buse : Je vais l'appeler...
Denver !
Thomas : Bien vu. La Buse : De quoi ? Iris : Ah oui, c'est vrai tu connais pas le dessin animé. La Buse : Le quoi ? En tout cas, c'est mon ami et bien plus encore.
Même si la mère terrorisée. Iris : Non, ça doit être lié au fait que tu aies exterminer son espèce.
Iris : Bon, allez en route petit lapin. Lapin : Ok, mais vous savez j'ai un prénom et sur l'application-
Iris : On n'a pas le temps. Emmène-nous, Thomas, La Buse, en route. La Buse : Non, les des-amis.
Laissez-moi. J'ai trouvé ma place au calme avec Denver. Je me suis construit ma petite vie ici.
Et j'ai vu des gros insectes qui ont l'air très appétissants. Thomas : Ah bon ? T'es sûr ? Iris : Bon, bah, merci pour tout, La Buse.
Tu peux être fier à sauver le monde- Lapin : Il n'y a pas le temps pour me mettre 5 étoiles mais pour faire ses adieux tout le monde prend son temps.
La Buse : Allez-y. Thomas : Au revoir, l'ami. Je suis sûr qu'on va se croiser. Avec ta nouvelle
cicatrices, ton armée en mécanique et ton ami dinosaure, t'as un tout nouveau style.
Si des gens voulaient le dessiner il serait de quoi s'amuser. Iris : En route vers le laboratoire- Lapin : Retemporalisation ! La Buse : Au revoir !
Narrateur : Ça me fait vraiment bizarre. Eliott est parti pour de bon. Mais c'est quoi ça ? Épisode 10 ?
Ah. On a enfin donné le scénario du prochain épisode.
Vous savez quoi, je ne vais pas le lire et découvrir la fin de la saison comme vous.
À la semaine prochaine.
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouté et à la semaine prochaine pour le dernier épisode de l'épopée temporelle.